the house will be in order the number of
house seats allocated to each u.s
state is determined by a nationwide
census
and the exclusion of what president
donald trump describes as
aliens who are not in a lawful
immigration status
could directly impact on the composition
of the house
for example there are an estimated two
million residents in california
whose legal status is unclear and to
exclude them from the count
would result in the democrat leading
state losing as many as three seats
in congress four separate three judge
panels have all unanimously concluded
that the presidential memorandum
violates the constitution
and existing federal law but
it's a new supreme court that is now
hearing the case
before the death of justice ruth bader
ginsburg in september last year
the court was equally balanced along
ideological lines
on the one side four conservative
leaning judges
on the other side four less conservative
judges
and at the center chief justice john
roberts who has had a casting vote one
way or another
in a number of cases but a recent
decision striking down the right to the
new york governor to limit the number of
people visiting places of worship
has revealed a fundamental shift in the
nature of the court
five justices including the newly
appointed amy coney barrett
decided the anti-pandemic measure
violated
the constitutional right to religious
freedom
outvoting what is now a new more liberal
minority the three justices appointed by
president trump
have entrenched a conservative group in
the country's highest court
for the foreseeable future the census
case called trump v new york
is an early test of whether this court
is prepared to bend the rule of law
at presidential whim and it's a decision
that's likely to be taken quickly
by law president trump must inform
congress of how house seats will be
apportioned
by the 10th of january next year
mike hanna al-jazeera washington